all right while student athletes are
shooting hoops in indiana tourists and
locals are in sports books
and casinos wait a second people bet on
men's basketball shocking information
hecarim here live this morning over at
the luxor with a look at a watch party
for all ages hector good morning to you
well hey there good morning guys you
know the excitement is back and you know
yeah as you just mentioned people are
placing their bets coming to town to
place those bets so
uh we're at the hyperx esports arena and
earlier we showed you this massive
screen where people will be able to
watch the games
starting at nine o'clock this morning
and now we're about to get a
behind-the-scenes look
at what it takes for the crew to play
those games on that massive
4k screen now they have one large screen
but in addition to that they have
several others out there joining us live
we have jim
to explain the brains out here good
morning good morning how are you thanks
for having me
thanks for talking with us so what do we
have here we have a lot of screens and
a lot of buttons yes that's right this
is our front of the house production
room
and so already we have each game
scheduled and programmed into when they
first tip off
with the stagger being a half hour
between each different start
the networks will already programmed in
so
any customer that comes in any fan will
come in they don't have to worry their
game will tip off at the right time and
they will be able to catch the entire
game
and today's first game tips off on
channel 8. yes that's right cbs
so that's really cool this is just
overlooking the area down below where
the watch party will be hosted
it's open to all ages it's smoke free
and uh just tell us about the new way to
watch the game now
you have really assigned seating yes
there is a signed seating
each different quadrant of seating is
socially distanced to be
uh to be socially conscious and and uh
have the sanitary
viewing like we've done and for the last
six months here at the hyperx esport
arena
we're excited to invite as many people
as we can to come and watch
but we want to make sure that we are
providing everybody
the the best viewing option uh in a safe
and healthy environment let's talk about
the tickets 75
and what do they include 75 dollars
includes five drink tickets
and it can go all day so we do encourage
everybody to come in
but pace yourself because there's a lot
of basketball to be watched
a lot and it all starts in just a few
hours jim thank you for your time so
we'll be moving around and show you a
different part of the venue here
so you guys alex and john this is really
cool you know on my way here i noticed a
lot more
traffic than normal along the boulevard
and even the parking lot here at the
luxor
seemed like it was packed so a lot of
people in town excited for the games
today right
absolutely and you know alex the games
uh start this afternoon so you don't
have to wait until the evening or
whatever
uh you can get cracking early on today
so that's the best part of ncaa men's
basketball
yes that's the perk of being there
hector at five in the morning you get
the best in the house
all right stay right here all day